AUTOPSY OF GEORGE FLOYD.
HIS CONCLUSION SEEMED TO
CONTRADICT WHAT THE PRELIMINARY
AUTOPSY SAID.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
WE HAVE BEEN VERY CLEAR.
PEACEFUL PROTESTING SURROUNDING
THIS HORRIFIC DEATH OF GEORGE
FLOYD ARE WARRANTED AND
SUBSTANTIAL.
AND THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
NOBODY LIKES WHAT THEY SAW.
IN A COUNTRY NOW THAT IS SPLIT,
THIS IS NOT REPUBLICAN-DEMOCRAT.
THIS IS NOT
CONSERVATIVE-LIBERAL.
UNIVERSALLY, EXCEPT FOR MAYBE A
FEW WARRIORS IN THEIR BASEMENT
IN THEIR UNDERPANTS WERE ALL IN
AGREEMENT THAT THE KNEE ON THE
KNACK FOR THAT SUSTAINED PERIOD
OF TIME IS A DEATH SENTENCE FOR
SOMEBODY.
PERIOD.
ANGER, GRIEF SURROUNDING THAT
VIDEO.
SOMETHING ALL AMERICANS FEEL.
FLOYD WAS HANDCUFFED ON THE
GROUND WHEN THE MINNEAPOLIS
OFFICER DEREK CHAUVIN APPLIED
LETHAL PRESSURE TO THE MOST
VULNERABLE PART OF THE HUMAN
BODY, THE NECK.
IT WENT OVER 8 MINUTES.
SMASHING HIS FACE INTO THE
PAVEMENT WHILE SCREAMING THAT HE
CANNOT BREATHE.
WE WILL GET TO THE AUTOPSY IN A
MINUTE.
WE DISCOVERED THAT THERE WERE
FACIAL SCARS.
THAT’S HOW PINNED DOWN HE WAS TO
THE PAVEMENT.
UNFORTUNATELY OTHER POLICE
OFFICERS COULD HAVE STEPPED IN
AND DID NOT.
WHY?
WE HAVEN’T HEARD FROM THEM YET.
WE NEED TO.
ACCORDING TO THE INDEPENDENT
AUTOPSY CONDUCTED BY DR. MICHAEL
BADEN, GEORGE FLOYD WAS KILLED
BY THAT ACT, AS A MATTER OF FACT
THERE’S A REPORT OUT OF THE
EXAMINER’S OFFICE IN MINNESOTA
THAT SAYS THE SAME THING.
THE PRELIMINARY REPORTS SUGGEST
THE OPPOSITE.
WE KNOW THE PRESIDENT HAS ASKED
FOR AN EXPEDITED INVESTIGATION
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING, THAT
INCLUDES THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, THE FBI, THE CIVIL
RIGHTS DIVISION COORDINATING
WITH LOCAL POLICE DEPARTMENT IN
THE AREA AND LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS.
JUSTICE WILL BE SERVED.
CHAUVIN HAS BEEN CHARGED WITH
THIRD-DEGREE MURDER AND
MANSLAUGHTER.
THE OTHER OFFICERS STOOD BY AND
DID NOTHING TO STOP HIM.
THEY HAVE ALL BEEN FIRED.
MORE STATE CHARGES ON FEDERAL
CHARGES COULD BE ON THE WAY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS DIRECT THE
DOJ TO GO FORWARD WITH THE CIVIL
RIGHTS INVESTIGATION.
THAT MEANS YES, FEDERAL CHARGES
VERY POSSIBLE IN THIS CASE.
SADLY NOW THE LIFE AND DEATH OF
GEORGE FLOYD IS GETTING
OVERSHADOWED BY CRIMINALS,
ANARCHISTS, THOSE LOOTING AND
BURNING, GROUPS LIKE ANTIFA WHO
ARE WREAKING HAVOC ON THE
STREETS OF OUR CITIES.
AT THIS POINT, HUNDREDS OF
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN UTTERLY
DESTROYED.
STOREFRONTS SMASHED IN, FIRES
BURNING OUT OF CONTROL, LOOTING
IN MANY GREAT AMERICAN CITIES.
BUSINESS OWNERS VIOLENTLY
ATTACKED.
ROCHESTER, NEW YORK, A WOMAN WAS
SAVAGELY ASSAULTED BY AN ANGRY
MOB OF YOUNG MEN WHO WERE
VANDALIZING HER STORE.
A MAN IN DALLAS, THIS IS
UNCONSCIONABLE.
HE WAS BEATEN UNCONSCIOUS.
DOZENS OF SECRET SERVICE AGENTS
PROTECTING THE WHITE HOUSE.
THEY WERE INJURED BY RIOTING --
RIOTERS THROWING PROJECTILES.
POLICE OFFICERS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY FACE SIMILAR INJURIES.
ONE NYU-TRAINED LAWYER ARRESTED
FOR THROWING A MOLOTOV COCKTAIL.
ST. PATRICK’S CATHEDRAL IN
NEW YORK CITY WAS DEFACED WITH
CURSE WORDS AND BLM SPRAY.
THE CHURCH OF THE PRESIDENT WAS
LIT ON FIRE.
THE PRESIDENT MADE A VISIT THERE
LATER THIS AFTERNOON AND BELIEVE
IT OR NOT, IT’S ONE SMALL PART
OF THE UNACCEPTABLE LEVEL OF
VIOLENCE AND ANARCHY FROM THIS
WEEKEND’S RIGHTS.
>> HANDS UP!
>> DON’T SHOOT!
>> GO HOME!
>> WE SUPPORT THE RIGHT OF
PEACEFUL PROTESTERS AND WE HEAR
THERE -- THEIR PLEAS.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING NOW HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH JUSTICE OR
PEACE.
>> I SAW PEOPLE CONVERGING ON
THE POLICE VEHICLE.
I SAW PEOPLE THROWING THINGS AT
THAT’S NOT PEACEFUL PROTEST.
>> [BLEEP]
[BLEEP]
>> THIS IS NOT IN THE SPIRIT OF
MARTIN LUTHER KING JR.
THIS IS CHAOS.
>> Sean: LET ME BE CLEAR.
WHAT WE ARE ALL WITNESSING IS A
COUNTRY IS A FUNDAMENTAL FAILURE
OF LIBERAL GOVERNMENTS, LIBERAL
GOVERNORS, LIBERAL MAYORS ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
PHILADELPHIA, MINNEAPOLIS,
CHICAGO, NEW YORK, LOS ANGELES,
SAN FRANCISCO, OAKLAND AND OTHER
MAJOR CITIES NOW RAVAGED BY
CHAOS.
THEY HAVE BEEN RUN BY DEMOCRATS
FOR DECADES.
THE FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE, THAT
WOULD BE THE GOVERNORS.
THAT WOULD BE THE MANNERS.
THAT WOULD BE LOCAL POLICE
DEPARTMENTS SURROUNDING THE
POLICE DEPARTMENTS.
STATE TROOPERS THAT GET CALLED
UP.
STATE GUARDSMEN GET CALLED UP,
AND OF COURSE THEY ALWAYS HAD AT
THEIR READY THE PRESIDENT WHO
HAS BEEN SAYING NOW FOR SOME
TIME HE HAS THE NATIONAL GUARD
READY FOR ANYBODY THAT WILL ASK
FOR IT.
THAT’S THEIR ROLE TO ASK.
NOW THE PRESIDENT HAS STEPPED
UP.
THE PRESIDENT SAID IF YOU DON’T
CONTROL IT, I WILL.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN CITIES HAS
BEEN GRUMBLING FOR DECADES.
THE SCHOOL SYSTEMS IN THESE VERY
SAME CITIES, THEY HAVE BEEN IN
FAILING OUR CHILDREN, OUR
AMERICAN FAMILY FOR DECADES.
THEY HAVE NOW FAILED GENERATIONS
OF CHILDREN.
IN MANY CASES, THE VIOLENCE IS
COMPLETELY OUT OF CONTROL AND
HAS BEEN EVEN BEFORE ALL OF THIS
HAPPENED.
IN CHICAGO, 200 MURDERS THIS
YEAR AND WE ARE NOT EVEN HALFWAY
THROUGH THE YEAR.
IT’S BEEN GOING ON FOR YEARS.
WHY HASN’T THAT PROBLEM BEEN
SOLVED.
DEMOCRATIC MAYORS AND GOVERNORS
IN THESE CITIES AND STATES MAKE
A LOT OF PROMISES EVERY TWO
YEARS, EVERY FOUR YEARS, THEY
SPEND A LOT OF TAXPAYER MONEY,
TAX THEIR CITIZENS TO DEATH.
EVEN AFTER DEATH.
WHEN THEY ARE NEEDED, GUESS
WHAT, WHEN THEY ARE MOST NEEDED,
NOWHERE TO BE FOUND, JUST LIKE
THEY BLEW IT AND WERE NOT
PREPARED AT ALL FOR CORONAVIRUS
IN STATES LIKE NEW YORK,
NEW JERSEY, PENNSYLVANIA AND
MICHIGAN.
WELL, DONALD TRUMP BAIL THEM OUT
THERE.
THEY KNOW ABOUT ANTIFA.
THEY KNOW ABOUT THESE
ANARCHISTS.
THEY KNOW THE RISKS THEY POSE.
THEY HAVE LET THIS BUILD AND
BUILD AND BUILD AND DO NOTHING
TO STOP THE VIOLENCE.
MAYBE ON NIGHT ONE THEY COULD
HAVE SAID THEY WEREN’T PREPARED.
WHAT’S YOUR EXCUSE FOR NIGHTS
TWO, THREE, FOUR, FIVE?
THEY KNEW THAT CITIES WERE
VULNERABLE TO LOOTING AND
VIOLENCE DURING TIMES OF UNREST.
YET, THEY ARE TOTALLY UNPREPARED
FOR ANYTHING AS ALWAYS.
THIS IS BEYOND AN EPIC FAIL, A
DISGRACE, TOTAL COMPLETE
DERELICTION OF THEIR DUTY.
HOW DO YOU LET RIOTERS BURN DOWN
A POLICE STATION?
NOT ONE BUT TWO.
HOW DO YOU LET THEM LOOT STORY
AFTER STORY AFTER STORY?
HOW DO YOU LET THEM DESTROY
ALREADY STRUGGLING BUSINESSES
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHEN, BY
THE WAY, ALL WEEK WHEN YOUR
PEOPLE WERE GETTING BEATEN IN
THE STREETS, WHERE WERE YOU?
WHERE WAS YOUR PLAN?
WHY DID THE POLICE RETREAT?
WHY DIDN’T YOU RESTORE ORDER?
THERE WAS NO PLAN, A SPECTACULAR
FAILURE ON EVERY LEVEL.
THE DAMAGE, THE CARNAGE, THE
WRECKAGE WILL GO ON FOR YEARS AS
A RESULT OF THIS.
THIS CAST NEEDS TO END NOW.
AS AMERICA’S MAYOR,
RUDY GIULIANI, WILL JOIN US
LATER.
HE SAID FRIDAY OF THE FIRST
PERSON THROWS A STONE, THEY GET
ARRESTED.
THE SECOND PERSON GETS ARRESTED.
THE THIRD PERSON, THEY ARE
LIKELY NOT GOING TO THROW THE
STONE BECAUSE THEY KNOW THERE
WILL BE REAL CONSEQUENCES.
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW THERE WILL
BE REAL CONSEQUENCES.
BY THE WAY, PASSIVE POLICING
DURING A RIOT IS NEVER GOING TO
WORK.
DISPENSING LARGE CROWDS, WELL,
IT’S NOT BRAIN SURGERY.
IT’S NOT FUN.
MAKING ARRESTS, CONFRONTING
AGITATORS, NOT EASY WORK.
BUT THESE GOVERNORS AND MAYORS
MUST AUTHORIZE, WELL, IT’S
SIMPLE.
YOU SET UP A PERIMETER.
YOU AND FOR US, IF YOU HAVE
CURFEWS, YOU ENFORCE THEM.
OVERWHELMING NONLETHAL FORCE
INCLUDING EVERY TOOL AT THEIR
DISPOSAL BUILDER ON THE
PARAMETERS AND THEN YOU USE
WHAT’S NECESSARY SAFELY TO
DISPERSE THE CROWD.
NOT BRAIN SURGERY.
THAT WOULD MEAN TEARGAS, MACE IF
NECESSARY.
RUBBER BULLETS.
YOU HAVE THE POLICE IN PLACE,
THE PERIMETER IS SMALL ENOUGH,
THEY WILL DISPERSE.
IF THEY NEEDED ADDITIONAL HELP,
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
SAYING FOR DAYS THEY WILL SEND
HELP.
NOW THE PRESIDENT, WELL, HE WILL
GO IN AND CLEAN UP THEIR MESS,
JUST LIKE HE HANDLED THEIR LACK
OF PREPARATION FOR FOR A PANDEMI
AS ANDREW McCARTHY POINTED OUT
IN A RECENT ARTICLE, THE
PRESIDENT HAS THE CONSTITUTIONAL
AUTHORITY AND POWER THROUGH THE
NATIONAL GUARD AND OF COURSE OUR
MILITARY THEM.
IT’S CALLED INSURRECTION ACT.
HE HAS THE FULL AUTHORITY TO GO
INTO THESE STATES AND RESTORE
ORDER WHICH HE NOW MUST DO
BECAUSE THEY DIDN’T DO IT.
IF THESE LIBERAL MAYORS AND
GOVERNORS IN MOST CASES ARE
UNABLE AND UNWILLING TO PROTECT
THEIR OWN CITIZENS, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WELL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE CANNOT ALLOW THE RIGHTEOUS
CROWDS OF PEACEFUL PROTESTERS TO
BE DROWNED OUT BY AN ANGRY MOB.
I WILL FIGHT TO PROTECT YOU.
I AM YOUR PRESIDENT OF LAW AND
ORDER.
THAT IS WHY I AM TAKING
IMMEDIATE PRESIDENTIAL ACTION TO
STOP THE VIOLENCE AND RESTORE
SECURITY AND SAFETY IN AMERICA.
MAYORS AND GOVERNORS MUST
ESTABLISH AN OVERWHELMING
LAW ENFORCEMENT PRESENCE UNTIL
THE VIOLENCE HAS BEEN QUELLED.
IF A CITY OR STATE REFUSES TO
TAKE THE ACTIONS THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO DEFEND THE LIFE AND
PROPERTY OF THEIR RESIDENCE,
THEN I WILL DEPLOY THE
UNITED STATES MILITARY AND
QUICKLY SOLVE A PROBLEM FOR THEM
THEM.
>> Sean: MOMENTS AGO, THE
PRESIDENT WALKED TO THE SCENE OF
THIS WEEKENDS UNREST IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., OUR NATION’S
CAPITAL.